estaba viendo directamente a la cámara
no importa
como entre a pixar
bueno yo crecí dibujando y pintando y mi
papá trabajaba para ibm así que había
computadoras a mi alrededor y recuerdo
que un día mi hermano me dijo oye mira
esto puedes animar imágenes en la
computadora y para mí fue como se ve
divertido de pequeño mi papá me llevó al
departamento de investigación de ibm
donde john lasseter estaba dando una
plática sobre animación digital y eso me
dejó atónito estaban mostrando looks o
juniors por primera vez o al menos por
primera vez para nosotros y nos decía
cómo se encogía antes de saltar y su
seguimiento después de que brincaba
bueno cuando iba a la escuela empecé a
estudiar ciencias de la computación y me
certifica en artes visuales aunque
cuando estuve en artes visuales el
programa estaba más orientado a las
bellas artes y no a las artes gráficas
así que nadie hablaba de animación
pero había un cuarto lleno de
computadoras donde nos sentábamos sin
hacer nada así que las configuré para
renderizar mi primer corto animado
i
pues si en la escuela pasé mucho tiempo
aprendiendo sobre matemáticas y
tecnología detrás de la animación
digital pero es realmente en el trabajo
donde me convertí en animador